[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I noticed that okay okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we're just hours away from the kickoff
for your Las Vegas raid we're about a
year away from the kickoff for your Las
Vegas Raiders and good thing they'll
have an Tonio Brown
well maybe Jerry Rice will come back you
may not be able to rely on the Raiders
this year but you can rely on me and
fantasy football it's time for your
fantasy fire drill live from the sports
book at Caesars Palace in Fabulous Las
Vegas it's your fantasy fire drill and
here's your host madcap
all right welcome in everybody Michaela
great job right Michaela its Nicole you
sticking around for the show can I go
now yeah alright anyway welcome in to
your fantasy fire drill in his week
number one for real I'm not counting
Thursday night because we know that
didn't go very well I am mad camping yes
this is your fantasy fire drill we are
here at Caesars at the sports book where
you can find us each and every Sunday
11:30 Eastern 8:30 Pacific make this
part of your week 1 week 2 week every
week routine because we will get you
covered with the inactives with the
injuries with my latest rankings with
sleepers and we'll take plenty of your
questions along the way so drop them in
there we have you covered welcome in to
another NFL season to the hundred and
probably like the 30th fantasy football
season
now one thing happened this week that is
not going to involve anything in today's
games
that's a Antonio Brown because the
Antonio Brown look they already got the
picture he is a New England Patriot now
if you didn't know he wasn't on the
roster by 4:00 Eastern on Saturday which
means he cannot play and will not be
part of the Patriots tonight against the
Steelers so no a be yet I know you have
plenty of questions about it we will get
to it certainly we'll talk a little bit
about the Raiders Tyrell Williams Darren
Walter and Hunter Renfro but a be not a
Raider is a patriot we'll talk more
about that in the coming days but now
let's get into our inactive so it's not
a bad week it's week one it better not
be a bad week for injuries this list
will probably be a lot longer spoiler in
the coming weeks here's what we know and
we'll update these as we get the
official enactors but we can tell you
what we know right now
Odell Beckham jr. has a hip issue Odell
Beckham jr. has a hip issue we're not
worried about it he will be active today
Stefon Diggs was a question mark and we
can now tell you for sure Stefon Diggs
is in he will play today I do like Adam
feeling a bit more digs has struggled
when he's played through injury but
officially active today a Mike Evans has
a illness I had one too on Monday I'm
active today and so is Mike Evans love
him against the Niners Niners Buccaneers
could be a sneaky good day
for fantasy purposes because the
defenses are not good there Robbie
Anderson looks like he'll play through
his injury but it's a tough matchup
against for davyous white and the
Buffalo Bills he is outside my top 35
receivers for this week now move over to
here Alshon Jeffery looks good to go
bicep injury not a big deal at all like
him against Washington I think the
Eagles get off to a very nice start this
week for a very strong season coming for
the Eagles Jordan Reed with the
concussion he will not play and yet
another concussion in his career that
leaves Vernon Davis now as the starter
for the Washington Redskins and we'll
talk more about that team and who you
can look to get into your lineup today
as a potential sleeper but Jordan Reed
will not play and I can also tell you
this Adrian Peterson is inactive today
he's a healthy for the Washington
Redskins Adrian Peterson will not play
as they don't feel like they need him on
the active roster we'll talk more about
that as well [ __ ] Coetzee obviously
playing tomorrow night not expected to
be out there they just brought in Kenny
Stills yeah yeah it's a fairly
significant injury for cootie that
happened in the preseason you have
stills
obviously of DeAndre Hopkins yeah will
fuller they're loaded up there with Duke
Johnson and now Carlos Hyde so don't
expect them against Saint in another
potentially very high scoring affair
which is good for fantasy purposes when
they take on the New Orleans Saints
Albert Wilson Albert Wilson a bit up in
the air somebody I want you to keep an
eye on though on the waiver wire if he's
sitting out there don't worry about this
week against the Ravens it wasn't a good
matchup anyway but he might be the top
option in Miami's offense now that Kenny
Stills is in Miami
by the way Jordan Reed now officially
out not a surprise there but that is
up-to-date so we gave you everything we
know right now as the official inactives
come down we will post them and revisit
this many times but now let's start to
get to your questions we'll get to
plenty of them throughout the show
continue to drop them in the comments as
we get you ready for a week one aye 59
start Zeke this week or no I think he'll
be a top five running back no doubt
about it don't worry about the matchup
or that he's missed time get Zeke in
your lineup with confidence this week
retro what will the Patriots fantasy
outlook the post a be signing
look I think everybody's targets take a
hit I think Josh Gordon might take the
biggest hit of all because I don't think
his role has to be important look Grady
loves Julian Edelman they're best
friends they go to the Kentucky Derby
together and they wear terrible suits
and hats that's not going to change they
didn't really have a tight end so they
still don't and maybe that's where you
see a B pick up a lot of targets I think
everybody has more scoring opportunities
because the office is better
who wins out again Tom Brady easily a
top-ten quarterback the rest of the way
good question has Jude's room why is no
one talking about Joe Mixon well they
don't have AJ Green and that's a big
story he won't be there today against
Seattle
mix-ins fine there's some old line
issues there he may need to be a gtp or
garbage time producer not only today but
a lot of this season still a solid
running back not in the best situation
continuing on here king of beasts who's
the greatest kicker in fantasy football
I love al Del Greco of the Houston or
Houston Oilers but right now it's Justin
Tucker oh my pugs always pick a kicker
they're like Jason Myers of the Seattle
Seahawks today
yeah there's ticker advice in Week one
lion world 29 start Tevin Coleman where
Damian Williams at the Flex report out
there today from rap sheet that will see
McCoy for 15 to 20 snaps not scared off
by Damien limbs at all he's a top 15
play and I would play him over at 7
Coleman who's also in my top 30 Jay Lee
well who should I pick up on the Raiders
Renfro or Waller Ren flow which could be
a new nickname but Renfro if you need a
tight end I like Waller this week and on
the end beyond by the way he's at number
12 for me a tight end so I would look to
him first
now we asked for your video questions
this week let's see what we have
hey Matt it's deja just wondering do you
generally like our B's our wide
receivers more in the Flex spot
typically especially in PPR I like
running backs more because they have
more opportunity they can carry the ball
they can catch the ball
I love pass catching running backs that
I can throw in the Flex spot because
they have chances to pick up points
through the air and speaking of that
that leads us into our sleepers
sleepies as they've been called for
years like this bear is doing but take
this bear out of hibernation the Chicago
Bears didn't get out of hibernation on
Thursday we're gonna get you set if
you're behind because the David
Montgomery and everyone who played in
that game let's help you out with three
sleepers that I have for you this week
maybe you checked out my article comes
out every Friday we go it's a little
more detail now Chris Thompson is a name
that may have burned you in the past
because of injuries what do we talked
about earlier Jordan Reed is out today
here is the all-star group that the
Washington Redskins were trotting out
there
Terry McLaury Trey Quinn and Paul
Richardson are on top of the depth chart
I just missed making that team they have
Vernon Davis that's nice
they're gonna get blown out by the
Eagles today and when you're playing
from behind that guy's gonna catch the
football
there is a player flex question as we
just took who can help you out
when we're talking about these deep
sleepies 10 to 12 points in a PPR Chris
Thompson can do that he could be a game
breaker but it'll be there hurry up back
remember
no Adrian Peterson for the Washington
Redskins positive game script in a game
the Redskins will lose same thing I feel
for Deion Lewis for the Tennessee Titans
everybody talking up Derek Henry what a
great season he had he won people
fantasy championships he was also
attrocious for the other 12 weeks of the
season and guess what
the Browns they're gonna beat the Titans
up today Derek Henry if he does one
thing it's run the football if he
doesn't do another thing it's catch the
ball the guy doesn't catch the ball but
Dion Lewis catches the ball so if the
Titans are playing from behind and if
you believe the Browns offense they will
be that's the guy who's in the game late
positive game flow playing from behind
means Dion Lewis is catching passes for
the Tennessee Titans and one more this
could be your cheap DFS quarterback this
could be someone you need to confidently
play at the quarterback position in your
second role it's Matthew Stafford and I
know last year he let you down
he played with broken bones in his back
I'm not holding that against them he's
healthy now
Kenny gala day Marvin Jones TJ Hawkinson
carry on Johnson and oh by the way they
take on an hour
on a secondary down Patrick Peterson
because suspension and Robert Alford
because of injury the top two corners
are down in a defense that's not that
good to begin with a healthy Stafford
can pick that defense apart
he's got top ten potential for week
number one those are some deep sleepers
but now we get some more of your
questions maybe that helps maybe you've
gotten your questions answered about
what I've said today but now will help
me more Jade SEO well Calvin Ridley be a
solid replacement for a big well you
probably had a B isn't lowing wide
receiver one or high in wide receiver
two so I wouldn't go that level with
Ridley as he takes on the Minnesota
Vikings today it's not an easy matchup
he's probably a low-end wide receiver to
high and wide receiver three so don't
have a be expectations karen says copper
Christian Kirk hey I'm all in on Cup
fill it up and fill it up again I think
he'd be top twenty this week against the
Carolina Panthers let's play Cooper come
works
Marlon Mac or Duke Johnson I like Duke
more and a potential very high-scoring
affair on Monday Night Football
between the Saints and the Texans don't
love mac against the Chargers as we keep
it moving deadly shot start cook or for
net I love Dalvin cook this week no team
has given up more receptions to the
running back position over the last
three years and the Atlanta Falcons
Dalvin cook has a shot to be number one
this week I will play him with
confidence
Garza now that a bee is in New England
is Damaris Thomas to drop candidate not
only should he not be on your fantasy
team he might not be a New England
Patriot come tomorrow so yes
forget about Demaryius Thomas the
uniball hello Sean
I show a wall are on your sleepers list
do you play them over a gallop or mile
Sanders in the Flex probably not I
actually like gallop as a sleeper
against the Giants and I'm a big miles
and earth fan so I like having them on
your roster but I don't think it needs
to be in your lineup this week I'm
hearing we have yet another question
supposedly it's from celebrity let's
find out Matt was good at so Joe
Chad whatever you want to call me but AJ
Green is down don't fret because Tyler
Boyd proved last year that he can to
carry the workload of a number one
receiver therefore with AJ being out
this upcoming week would it be in week
one who do you think I have
who do you think you should pick who do
you think anyone that likes the bangles
should pick as their number one receiver
Tyler Boyd so he's asking about Tyler
board and Chad Ochocinco alright we're
now friends I don't know if you know Bo
yeah why he did pick him up didn't work
out
Tyler Boyd can he be the man in
Cincinnati he will be the man because of
no AJ Green but Tyler Boyd himself told
me he benefits from being on the field
AJ Green cuz coverage is pulled his away
from him well he's got Seattle today and
no AJ Green that's a problem for me
Boyd's a fine wide receiver to
opportunity will be there the quality of
those opportunities scares me I'll say
this I didn't think I would thank you
Chad Ochocinco hope to see you soon
guess what I think it might be Todd yes
the famous world famous piano it's time
from that moment
hi isn't this what you expected to see
on a Monday morning or a Sunday morning
or any morning probably not but you
didn't expect to watch it you watched on
Thursday either that was awful
it's burned into my brain sorry about
David Montgomery Toronto Wilson still
waiting for them to get a target Oh
Aaron Jones now you're not coming
through
hey are you happy to see that much more
on Mike Davis and no I don't want to
watch mr. Biscay play quarterback either
but I will tell you one thing it's week
one don't overreact to week one I'm
gonna tell you something you're not
gonna want to hear it some of your best
players in your lineup today are not
gonna come through for you and you're
gonna freak out why did I take that guy
in the third round why did I take that
guy in the second round cuz you're not
thinking about one week you're thinking
about November and December Julio Jones
had a bad week one last year they just
gave him 64 million dollars up front
the Falcons think big picture so should
you I know over overreaction Monday is
coming don't overreact
it's only one week and that has been in
that moment now let's give you some
updates here where we're at with our
updated inactives Robbie Anderson will
play today as I said I was concerned
about the injury don't like his matchup
I have him at wide receiver 40 in PPR so
he is in but I don't necessarily tell
you have to play him he's a wide
receiver for let's move on Albert Wilson
he will play today unfortunately it's
against the Baltimore Ravens so here's
what I could see happening he doesn't do
well everybody forgets about him he's a
nice one to go grab and just picked up
and throw on your roster because I don't
think today I'll go well but I do think
he's the best receiver for the Miami
Dolphins but just updating here also I'm
Jeffrey expected to play Beckham expect
to go through the hip and Mike average
through the through the illness it's not
a bad week for injuries but it will get
much worse let's get to more of your
questions as we continue to get more
information we continue to update and we
continue to help you and we go to the
questions right now Zee Gibbs how do you
feel about Eckler I think Echols would
be top 15 this week against the
Indianapolis Colts he is the man we
here Melvin Gordon could sit out likely
through week six so you keep the neck
lura round and hoping for a good game by
the way Justin Jackson a good deep
sleeper this week as well considering
with the questions Braun go 23 what
exactly does a Antonio Brown signing
with the Patriots mean for his fantasy
value I had him in the 10 to 12 range
with the Raiders and I probably keep
them there maybe with a little bit more
of a higher ceiling because when you go
from Derek Carr to Tom Brady it's
certainly an upgrade there's just a lot
of mouths to feed with the New England
Patriots Lamar Jackson or Winston
Winston's the top 5 quarterback for me
this week although I have Lamar Jackson
in my top 10 I love Winston against the
Buccaneers there's not a lot of defense
coming in that game moving on a Mears
Oriel Diggs Galilei woods need to sit 1
congrats on your championship with that
roster hey you want to avoid the injury
you could just sit digs down simple as
that nice spot to be in when you could
sit 3 top 15 receivers next question
here as we move along Patrick Bates
ranked these three for the week Chris
Godwin Amari Cooper and Josh Gordon
Patrick you may have looked at my
rankings ready because that's exactly
how I have them for this week as we
continue on Clevelander link josh corner
Tyler Boyd I do have Boyd higher just
because of opportunities remember Josh
Gordon has not been with the Patriots
for that long so I'm gonna go with Boyd
there don't love either player this week
hey we're live in the sports book here
at Caesars and we're gonna go out to the
crowd for a question hey Matt Greg here
big Niner fin besides George kiddo
which wire receivers gonna give me value
today I know we heard about Dante Pettis
and we heard that maybe Kyle Shanahan
didn't like him I think it was kind of
tough love there's a big question mark
about this receiving corps in San
Francisco and I think it's gonna
continue even past this week
I like Pettis the most but I could see
if you're reaching real deep you got a
cheap plane or DFS lineup marquise good
wood hitting a big play I think the
Niners could be kind of sneaky Kyle
Shanahan is an offensive genius he cares
about our fantasy team I know there's
not massive talent outside of Kidal and
Coleman and those kind of guys but I
could see them putting up some pretty
good numbers today against the
Buccaneers that is an offense that will
come through when they play a bad
defense that could happen today all
right back to enact as we go just
joining us
you updated information once again
Beckham fully expected to play it's a
hip issue it would be something I keep
an eye on during the week does he start
missing practices digs is gonna be good
to go not usually good playing through
injury matchup against Atlanta doesn't
scare me off too much my Kevin through
the illness he's fine they just have to
put him on injury report Robbie Anderson
will play tough matchup against the
bills he's outside my top 35 so if you
want to avoid them no problem don't
worry about that
I'll Shawn Jeffery expected to play with
the bicep injury against the Redskins I
think he'll be able to avoid Josh Norman
so play him with confidence as a top 20
wide receiver this week Jordan Reed is
out for the Redskins unfortunately has
he had another concussion Vernon Davis
will start in this place I do like Chris
Thompson as a sleeper and also while
he's not injured Adrian Peterson is a
healthy scratch today for the Washington
Redskins they don't feel the need to
have him on the roster guys we'll start
and Chris Thompson in there as a sleeper
[ __ ] cootie up in the air for tomorrow
night
don't worry about playing them if you're
thinking about it skip them and Albert
Wilson expected to play against the
Ravens today however I will note it's
not a great matchup but I would consider
picking him up to stash on the back end
of your bench those of your your
inactives that we know of right now and
I believe we're gonna get two more of
your oh I think it's the is that the
speed round
[Music]
well as you can see I talk for a living
for a reason because I got beat by a
five-year-old in a race speed is not my
thing and we're gonna find out if you
can coach speed because I hired a coach
who does a speed running video game
speed eating speed skating any other
speed so you know what this isn't the
dr. Phil book club let's go let's go
come on we take this let's be that off
get this on speed round
let's go as many questions we can get
through fire way Johnny Jeep
who's gonna have a bigger week for
surprising week one Andrews there Waller
I'll go Waller exact well for me this
week keep it going baby baby or Mayfield
I got Baker higher but I lube like I do
like Brady as a lower end QB one speed
round all right fire away H not
maggiorin how vs. Payton barb is a flex
option speaking of not speedy that's
these two guys right here I'll say
Howard's a little safer a base on Tom
Brady to leak QB one with a B in New
England look you've made out of drafting
him he's in the top 10 now potential top
you could go and speed round let's go
dim Deebo good a BB a Trojan horse for
the Pats no I don't think so
let's go speed round Spira see theories
now skywatcher 87 Marlon Mac or Matt
Breda I got Mac a little bit higher I
think we'll see breed up behind you
Paul's big going Irish oak 81 fits or
gallop for James Washington Fitz's the
safe play if you're down big from
Thursday take a shot on Michael guess
it's not called the lack of speed round
let's go Matt Ryan or Russell Wilson I
like Wilson today against Cincinnati
Bengals that was a quick one go 1 2 3
David 1 2 3 would you cut TD Westbrook
TJ more tire lock at the pickup Tyrell
Williams absolutely not speed round come
on come on baby it's everybody LJ
13-month a freeman of Arlen I dream it
against the Vikings not a great matchup
but I think I'll catch enough passes
I'll go with him BJ Goodson start Marvin
Jones Kurtis Samuel Robert woods in a TD
only a portion starting Robert Wood you
got to play Robert Irwin come on baby
screaming such a man 8167 start stealing
or carry on Johnson and a six-man half
point PPR
that's not a real lead start Adam
Thielen speed round
shags our Chargers D from delicious
waffles Jags against mahomes no thanks
I'll take the Chargers against the Colts
was I speeding enough
and just you lay off the waffles all
right well you know what hopefully you
have your lineup sets you could sit down
to a plate of waffles or whatever your
spreads gonna be because it's week one
and it's no more fake football it
matters and guess what if I didn't get
to your question I'm jumping in the
comments for the next half hour we'll
take care of you there and we'll take
care of you every week right here at the
Caesar sports book in Las Vegas join us
every Sunday 11:30 Eastern 8:30 Pacific
for your fantasy fire drill I'm Matt
Kamp
good luck in week one
you